can you briefly if it's just a small
tangent comment on your feelings about
gpt4 so just that you're impressed by
this rate of progress but where where is
it can gpt4
reason
what are like the intuitions what are
human interpretable words you can assign
to the capabilities of gpt4 that makes
you so damn impressed with it I'm both
very excited about it I'm terrified
interesting mixture of promotions all
the best things in life include those
two somehow yeah I can absolutely reason
anyone who hasn't played with it I
highly recommend doing that before
dissing it
it can do quite quite remarkable
reasoning
I've had to do a lot of things which I
realized I couldn't do that myself that
well even and
and obviously does it dramatically
faster than we do too when you watch a
type
and it's doing that while servicing a
massive number of other humans at the
same time at the same time it cannot
reason
as well as a human can on some tasks
just because it's obviously a limitation
from its architecture you know we have
in our heads what in geekspeak is called
the recurrent neural network there are
Loops information can go from this
neuron the base neuron to this neuron
and then back to this one you can like
ruminate on something for a while you
can self-reflect a lot uh these large
language models that are they cannot
like gpt4 it's it's a so-called
Transformer where it's just like a
one-way Street of information basically
and geekspeak it's called the feed
forward neural network
and it's only so deep so it can only do
logic that's that many steps and that
deep and it's not
and you can so you can create problems
which will fail to solve you know for
that reason
um
but the fact that it can do so amazing
things with this incredible simple
architecture already it's quite stunning
and and what we see in my lab at MIT
when we look inside
large language models to try to figure
out how they're doing it that's the key
core focus of our research it's called
um mechanistic interpretability in geek
speak you know you have this machine it
does something smart you try to reverse
reverse engineer see how does it do it
are you think of it also as artificial
Neuroscience that's exactly what
neuroscientists do with actual brains
but here you have the advantage that you
can you don't have to worry about
measurement errors you can see what
every neuron is doing all the time
and a recurrent thing we see again and
again
there's been a number of beautiful
papers quite recently by
by a lot of researchers some of them
here I am in this area is where when
they figure out how something is done
you can say oh man that's such a dumb
way of doing it and you immediately see
how it can be improved like for example
there was a beautiful paper recently
where they figured out how a large
language model stores certain facts like
Eiffel Towers in Paris
and they figured out exactly how it's
stored and where the proof that they
understood it was they could edit it
they changed some of the synapses in it
and then they asked it where's the
Eiffel Tower and it said it's in Rome
and then they asked you know how do you
get there oh how do you get there from
Germany oh you take this train and to
Roma Termini train station and this and
that and what might you see if you're in
front of it oh you might see the
Coliseum so they had edit it so they
literally moved it to Rome but it the
way it's storing this information it's
incredibly dumb for for any fellow nerds
listening to this there was a big Matrix
and a
and roughly speaking there are certain
row and column vectors which encode
these things and they correspond very
highly related principal components and
it will be much more efficient for
sparse Matrix just store it in the
database you know and and but and
everything so far we've figured out how
these things do our ways where you can
see they can easily be improved and the
fact that this particular architecture
has some roadblocks built into it is in
no way going to prevent um craft the
researchers from quickly finding
workarounds and making
other kinds of architectures
sort of go all the way so so it's um in
short it's turned out to be a lot
easier to build human close to human
intelligence than we thought then that
means our Runway is a species that
get our together has shortened
and it seems like the scary thing about
the effectiveness of large language
models uh so Sam Altman every
conversation with
and
he really showed that the leap from gpt3
to gpt4 has to do with just a bunch of
hacks
a bunch of
uh little Explorations but with the
smart researchers doing a few little
fixes here and there it's not some
fundamental leap and transformation in
the architecture and more data and more
compute and more data and compute but he
said the big leaps has to do with not
the data in the compute but just
learning this new discipline just like
you said so researchers are going to
look at these architectures and there
might be big leaps where you realize
wait why are we doing this in this dumb
way yeah and all of a sudden this model
is 10x smarter yeah and that that can
happen on any one day on anyone Tuesday
or Wednesday afternoon and then all of a
sudden you have a system that's 10x
smarter
um it seems like it's such a new
discipline it's such a new like we
understand so little about why this
thing works so damn well that uh the
linear Improvement of compute or
exponential but the steady Improvement
of compute steady Improvement of the
data may not be the thing that even
leads to the next leap it could be a
surprise little hack that improves
everything for a lot of little leaps
here and there because
because so much of this is out in the
open also
so many smart people are looking at this
and trying to figure out little leaps
here and there and it becomes this sort
of collective
race where if people a lot of people
feel if I don't take the leap someone
else with and this is actually very
crucial for for the other part of it why
do we want to slow this down so again
what this open letter is calling for it
is just pausing
all training
of uh
systems that are more powerful than gpt4
for six months
let's give a chance
for the labs to coordinate a bit on
safety and for societies to adapt give
the right incentives to the labs because
I you know you've interviewed a lot of
these
people who lead these labs and you know
just as well as I do that they're good
people they're idealistic people they're
doing this
first and foremost because they believe
that AI has a huge potential to help
humanity and uh
but at the same time they are trapped in
this horrible race to the bottom
have you read meditations on malloc
by Scott Alexander yes yeah it's a
beautiful essay on this poem by Ginsburg
where he interprets it as being about
this monster
it's this game theory monster that that
pits people into against each other in
this they race the bottom where
everybody ultimately loses the edit the
evil thing about this monster is even
though everybody sees it and understands
they still can't get out of the race
right
most a good fraction of all the bad
things that we humans do are caused by
moloch and I I like uh Scott Alexander's
um
naming of the monster so we can we
humans can think of it as an F A Thing
uh if you look at why do we have
overfishing why do we have more
generally the tragedy of the commons why
is it that um
I don't know if you've had her on your
podcast yeah she's become a friend yeah
great she made this awesome point three
recently that beauty filters that a lot
of female
influencers feel pressured to use or
exactly malloc in action again first
nobody was using them
and people saw them just the way they
were and then some of them started using
it
and becoming ever more Plastic Fantastic
and then the other ones that weren't
using it started to realize that
if they want to just keep their
their market share they have to start
using it too
and that and then you're in a situation
where they're all using it
and and none of them has any more market
share or less than before so
nobody gained anything everybody lost
and they have to keep becoming ever more
Plastic Fantastic also right
and uh
but nobody can go back to the old way
because it's just
too costly right the molok is everywhere
and um
molok is not a new arrival on on the
scene either we humans have developed a
lot of collaboration mechanisms to help
us fight back against molok through
various kinds of constructive
collaboration the Soviet Union and the
United States did sign the number of art
of Arms Control treaties
against moloch who is trying to stoke
them into
unnecessarily risky nuclear arms races
Etc et cetera and this is exactly what's
happening on the AI front this time
it's a little bit geopolitics but it's
mostly money where there's just so much
commercial pressure you know if you take
any of these
leaders of the top tech companies
and if they just say you know this is
too risky I want to pause
for six months they're going to get a
lot of pressure from shareholders and
others
we're like well you know if you pause
but those guys don't pause
we're
if you don't want to get our lunch eaten
yeah and shareholders even have the
power to replace the the executives in
the worst case right so
we did this open letter because we want
to help these idealistic Tech Executives
to do
what their heart tells them by providing
enough public pressure on the whole
sector
just pause so they can all pause
in a coordinated fashion and I think
without the public pressure none of them
can do it alone
push back against their shareholders no
matter how good-hearted they are smaller
is a really powerful foe
so the idea
is to
for the major developers of AI systems
like this so we're talking about
Microsoft Google
meta
and anyone else well open AI is very
close with Microsoft and there are
plenty of smaller players for example
anthropic which is very impressive
there's conjecture there's many many
players I don't want to make a long list
so leave anyone out and
um
for that reason it's so important that
some coordination happens that there's
external pressure on all of them saying
you all need the Pawns because then the
the people the researchers in they were
these organizations the leaders who want
to slow down a little bit they can say
their shareholders you know
everybody's slowing down because of this
pressure and and it's the right thing to
do
have you seen in history their uh
examples what's possible to pause the
model absolutely
and even like human cloning for example
you could make so much money on human
cloning
uh
why aren't we doing it
because biologists thought hard about
this like this is way too risky we they
got together well in the 70s in the
cinema and decided even
to stop a lot more stuff also just
editing the human germline right
Gene editing that goes in
to our offspring
and decided let's let's not do this
because it's too unpredictable what it's
going to lead to
we could lose control over what happens
to our species so they paused uh there
was a ton of money to be made there so
it's it's very doable but you just need
you need a public awareness of the of
what the risks are and the broader
Community coming in and saying hey let's
slow down and you know another another
common pushback I get today is we We
Can't Stop in the west because China
and in China undoubtedly they also get
told we can't slow down because the West
because both sides think they're the
good guy yeah
but look at human cloning you know
did China Forge ahead with human cloning
there's been exactly one human cloning
that's actually been done that I know of
it was done by a Chinese guy do you know
where he is now right in jail
and you know who put him there
who Chinese government
not because westerners said China look
this is no the Chinese government put
them there because they also felt
they like control
Chinese government if anything maybe
they are even more concerned about
having control then the Western
governments have no incentive of just
losing control over where everything is
going
and you can also see the Ernie bot that
was released by I believe Baidu recently
they got a lot of pushback from the
government and had to reigning in you
know in a big way
um I think once this basic message comes
out that this isn't an arms race it's a
suicide race
where everybody loses if anybody's AI
goes out of control it really changes
the whole dynamic it it's not
it's
I'll say this again because this is this
very basic point I think a lot of people
get wrong because a lot of people
dismiss the whole idea that AI can
really get
very superhuman because they think
there's something really magical about
intelligence such that it can only exist
in human Minds you know because they
believe that they think it's going to
kind of get to just more or less
gpd4 plus plus and then that's it
they don't see it as a super as a
suicide race they think whoever gets
that first they're going to control the
world they're going to win
that's not how it's going to be and we
can talk again about
the the scientific arguments from why
it's not going to stop there but
the way it's going to be is if if
anybody completely loses control and you
know you don't care if if
some some if someone manages to take
over the world who really doesn't share
your goals you probably don't really
even care very much about what
nationality they have you're not going
to like it it's much worse than today
uh who if it's if you live in orwellian
dystopia who you what do you care who's
created it right and if someone if it
goes farther and and
we just lose control even to the
machines
so that it's not US versus them it's US
versus it
you know what do you care who who
created this this underlying entity
which has goals different from humans
ultimately and we get marginalized we
get made obsolete we get replaced
that's why what I mean when I say it's a
suicide race you know it's um it's kind
of like we're rushing towards this cliff
but the closer the cliff we get the more
Scenic the views are and the more money
there is there and the more so we keep
going
but we have to also stop at some point
right quit while we're ahead and uh
it's um
it's a suicide race which cannot be won
but the way that really benefit from it
is
to continue developing awesome AI a
little bit slower so we make it safe
make sure it does the things that humans
want and create a condition where
everybody wins the technology has shown
us that you know geopolitics and and
politics in general is not a zero-sum
game at all